AGAIN, WELCOME.
WE ARE REALLY EXCITED TO HAVE
YOU AT OUR TABLE.
>> THANKS.
>>> WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
BREAKING NEWS BECAUSE JUST IN
TIME FOR SUMMER TOURISM, THE
EUROPEAN UNION WILL REOPEN ITS
BORDERS TO FULLY VACCINATED
VISITORS.
DID YOU HEAR THAT PART?
FULLY VACCINATED VISITORS.
AND THOSE FROM COVID-SAFE
COUNTRIES.
THE U.S. TRAVEL INDUSTRY ALREADY
IS SEEING A BIG, BIG JUMP IN
PASSENGERS.
APRIL BOOKINGS WERE UP 11% OVER
APRIL OF 2019, AND MANY PEOPLE
WANT TO FLY INTERNATIONALLY.
THEY ARE READY TO GO.
THIS MORNING, JETBLUE ANNOUNCES
IT WILL SOON FLY TO LONDON FOR
THE VERY FIRST TIME.
SO STARTING TODAY, YOU CAN BOOK
TRIPS BETWEEN NEW YORK'S JFK
AIRPORT AND LONDON'S HEATHROW
AND GATWICK AIRPORTS.
FLIGHTS BEGIN IN AUGUST, SO
START PACKING YOUR BAGS.
FIRST ON "CBS THIS MORNING,"
JETBLUE CEO, THERE HE IS, ROBIN
HAYES, JOINS US FROM THE
AIRLINE'S HANGAR AT JFK.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU BACK.
NICE TO SEE YOU, SIR.
>> GREAT TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> YOU'RE MAKING PEOPLE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT YOUR NEW FLIGHT
PLANS.
AND IT'S COMING AS THERE'S A LOT
OF TALK ABOUT A SURGE IN PRICES.
I HEARD YOU SAY, ROBIN HAYES,
THAT JETBLUE IS GOING TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO LOWER THE PRICES.
HOW CAN YOU DO THAT AND WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN EXACTLY?
>> WELL, NO, YOU KNOW, WHAT WE
DO BEST IS WE FLY TO PLACES THAT
HAVE REALLY HIGH FARES, AND WE
FIND A WAY OF LOWERING THEM.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING TODAY.
AS ANYONE KNOWS WHO'S FLOWN
ACROSS THE ATLANTIC OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS, THE AIRLINES
CHARGE EXTREMELY HIGH FARES,
PARTICULARLY FOR BUSINESS CLASS.
AND REALLY HAVE BEEN GOUGING
PEOPLE FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
SO AS OF TODAY, WE'RE ANNOUNCING
THAT WE ARE GOING TO PUT THAT
RIGHT JUST AS WE'VE BEEN DOING
FOR OVER 20 YEARS IN THE U.S.
AND WE'VE ANNOUNCED NEW FARES IN
BOTH OUR CORE AND OUR BUSINESS
CLASS, OUR NEW EXPERIENCE, WHICH
WE THINK WILL REDUCE FARES BY UP
TO ABOUT 50% OVER WHAT PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN PAYING IN THE PAST.
>> ROBIN, CAN YOU -- WHEN YOU
SAY PUT THAT -- PUT THAT RIGHT,
I LOVE YOUR ACCENT -- COULD YOU
GIVE US SOME NUMBERS SO WE KNOW
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
EXACTLY?
I'VE HEARD, YOU KNOW, YOU CAN
GET A FARE ABOUT $700 ROUNDTRIP.
$800 ROUNDTRIP.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR YOU
GUYS?
>> SURE.
SO SURE.
WHEN WE LAUNCH MINT ON JFK/LAX
IN 2014, WE STARTED FARES AT
$599.
WE'RE ANNOUNCING TODAY A NEW
FARE IN OUR MINT CABIN,
REIMAGINED MINT CABIN, SO
INDIVIDUAL SUITES FOR EVERYONE,
AT $1,979 ROUNDTRIP.
THAT INCLUDES ALL TAXES AND ALL
CHARGES.
THAT'S UNDER $1,000 EACH WAY FOR
PRIVATE SUITE EXPERIENCE WITH
FREE LIVE TV, FREE WI-FI, AND
ALL THE THINGS PEOPLE ARE USED
TO FROM JETBLUE.
>> ROBIN, LEVAR BURTON HERE.
WHY IS INTERNATIONAL TRAVEL SO
IMPORTANT TO THE AIRLINE
INDUSTRY RIGHT NOW?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, U.S. AIRLINES
HAVE SEEN A BIG BOUNCE BACK IN
THE DOMESTIC MARKET.
WE'VE SEEN THAT REALLY BE VERY
STRONG SINCE LATE FEBRUARY,
EARLY MARCH.
THERE'S A LOT OF PENT-UP DEMAND
FOR INTERNATIONAL TRAVEL.
IT'S HARDER BECAUSE THERE ARE
MORE RESTRICTIONS THAT
GOVERNMENTS HAVE PUT IN PLACE
AROUND COVID.
BUT AS THOSE RESTRICTIONS EASE
THROUGH VACCINATION REQUIREMENTS
OR TESTING REQUIREMENTS, THAT
PENT-UP DEMAND WILL -- WE'RE
EXPECTING AN EXTREMELY STRONG
SUMMER HERE WITH OUR NEW FLIGHTS
TO LONDON.
>> IT'S ANTHONY MASON.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF YOUR DOMESTIC
FLIGHT TRAVEL IS BACK, AND WHEN
DO YOU EXPECT IT TO BE BACK TO
PRE-PANDEMIC LEVELS?
>> WE ACTUALLY EXPECT THIS
SUMMER THE PEAK SUMMER TO BE
FLYING CAPACITY VERY SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE WERE FLYING IN SUMMER,
2019.
THAT TALKS TO HOW QUICKLY THINGS
HAVE REBOUNDED IN THE U.S.
ENOU
WE'VE GOT TO GET MORE
INTERNATIONAL OPEN, DO IT
SAFELY.
WE'VE GOT TO GIVE PEOPLE A
CHANCE TO TRAVEL, VISITING
PEOPLE THEY HAVEN'T SEEN FOR A
LONG TIME.
AND YOU KNOW, WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THAT HAPPENING OVER
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS.
NEWS FROM THE EU TODAY IS VERY,
VERY HELPFUL IN THAT REGARD.
>> ROBIN, DO YOU KNOW WHAT HER
SENTAGE OF YOUR CREW --
PERCENTAGE OF YOUR CREW, FLIGHT
ATTE
ATTENDANTS AND PILOTS ARE
VACCINATE?
DELTA WILL MAKE IT CRUCIAL FOR
NEW EMPLOYEES.
WILL YOU DO THE SAME?
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THE
VACCINATION RATES OF YOUR TEAM?
>> SO YOU KNOW, WE'RE -- THE
MAJORITY OF OUR CREW MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN VACCINATED.
YOU KNOW, WE ARE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGING IT.
WE'RE NOT MANDATING IT AT THIS
POINT.
IT IS LIKELY THAT SOME COUNTRIES
WILL REQUIRE OPERATING CREWS, SO
PILOTS AND IN-FLIGHT CREW
MEMBERS, TO BE VACCINATED IN THE
FUTURE.
IT'S STILL EARLY.
WE'RE STRONGLY ENCOURAGING THE
VACCINE FOR ALL OF OUR PEOPLE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
ROBIN HAYES, THANK YOU VER